[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et merci c'est à quelle je
m'appelle pires va leaf
généralement quand je prends la parole
en public c'est en tant que militante de
la cause des femmes et pour la lutte
contre les violences intrafamiliales
aujourd'hui ce sera différent je vais
parler de moi je vais essayer d'ouvrir
une petite fenêtre sur l'histoire de ma
vie etc qui m'a amené à m'engager en
tant que citoyenne tout simplement
mais avant j'aimerais partager avec vous
une histoire l'histoire d'une femme que
j'ai rencontrée et qui m'a bousculé
c'est le cas de le dire
cette femme avait connu un destin terme
ans en homme que je crois que je
n'oublierai jamais c'était il y a
quelques années nous avions ouvert dans
le quartier des camélias un espace de
parole destiné aux femmes d' équipe de
violence un matin une jeune femme entre
le visage fermé l'attitude presque style
et que tu attrapes sans dire bonjour au
sens présentée avec la violence et et
delà de la colère et de la désespérance
peut-être la voie elle dit on appuie de
morges et peut donner à mes enfants
après quelques secondes de flottement
je les invitais à entrer dans la pièce
que nous réservions habituellement pour
les entretiens confidentiels en face à
face
je n'ai pas vous raconter tout ce
qu'elle m'a été dit ce serait trop long
je l'appellerai mari
elle avait 27 ans deux enfants une fille
de 12 ans et un petit garçon de 4 ans
marry me racontait que lorsqu'elle est
née sa maman est partie de la technique
en abandonnant ses cinq premières qui
est venue la chercher deux jours plus
tard et qui l'a élevé jusqu'à l'art que
cinq ans à cinq ans mme di maria dû
venir habiter chez sa mère et le copain
de sa mère parce qu'il a fallu la
scolariser d'un grand mère habite est
bien trop loin de l'école communale de 7
ce village au lieu de l'attention de
l'affection qu'elle avait perdu tout
droit quand même je pense marie est
devenue la cause n de ce couple infernal
elle était battue pour et oui pour un an
elle était maltraitée et c'était souvent
plus les corvées que l'école à 11 ans
marie a été violée par un grand oncle
elle a voulu se débattre bien sûr mais
elle me disait madame vous savez il
était vieux mais il était fin à quatorze
enfin barry rencontre jeune homme à
peine plus âgé qu'elle inna regarde lui
sourit elle se sent exister elle
tendance épreuve est aussi tout de suite
pratiquement 7
mais le jeune homme il n'était pas prix
pourrait venir père et quand il assume
il a préféré s'éloigner et barry voilà à
15 ans maman d'une petite fille est à
nouveau abandonné lorsque je le
rencontrais mari elle venait juste de
quitter un un copain le père de son
petit garçon qui était alcoolique et
violent
elle s'était éloigné parce qu'elle
voulait d'abord se protéger mais surtout
méditer à protéger ses enfants avaient
trouvé un petit logement mais il fallait
bien sûr
le blé même sommairement ce logement il
fallait payer loyer la caution les
assurances et sur le plan financier mari
étaient deux à boire marie a parlé
pendant très longtemps quand elle est
partie au bout de deux heures avec
quelques provisions que nous avions ici
et comme de récupérer pour elle et nous
a dit timidement merci et j'ai vu dans
son regard quelque chose d'assez
indéfinissable quelque chose de
différent quelque chose qui ressemblait
à une petite lueur d'espoir cette femme
qui n'avait connu que des malheurs et
que des désillusions et qui se battait
courageusement pour ses enfants
très franchement ça m'a énormément
touché j'étais en colère je dois dire
j'étais révoltée mais je me suis dit
quelle que soit la situation le problème
que nous aurons à affronter
nous ne devons pas baisser les bras il y
à une solution
il y aura toujours une solution cette
histoire de marie m'a invité en quelque
sorte à revisiter ma propre histoire
même si elle est pas aussi tragique que
celle de paris je suis né aux avirons
dans un village rural je suis l'aîné de
neuf enfants donc une famille nombreuse
mon père était agriculteur il est né
aussi également un commerce au centre du
village
il travaillait beaucoup à l'âge de 10
ans et demi à l'âge de l'insouciance
pour les petites filles de mon âge j'ai
perdu ma mère
tel aviv est devant la halle et ses
quatre fils aime moi même des trois
petits frères âgés de cinquante trois
ans et le dernier de devoir
j'étais perdu mais je crois que je n'ai
pas saisi encore à ce moment là ce qui
nous arrivait mais très vite je me suis
rendu compte à quel point cette
disparition allait marquer durablement
et profondément le reste de notre vie
mon père avait fait appel le a de la
famille à une à vie pour ce que nous en
équipe très jeune et si une solution
provisoire
il estimait devoir donner une nouvelle
maman à ses enfants et il s'est remarié
très vite ma belle mère était quelqu'un
qui connaissait déjà ma mère est elle un
rage et de n'avoir pas fait comme elle
un mariage d'amour
l art était jalouse et frustré et un
s'est vengé sur nous nous sommes devenus
ses souffre-douleur
ça a été pour nous moi mes petits frères
vraiment des moments extrêmement
difficile extrêmement pénible et c'est
vrai que ces moments là ils ont marqué
notre vie mais je crois qu'elles ont
aussi forgé de personnalités à cette
époque là les filles de mon village
était destiné à se marier à fonder une
famille mon père lui il avait décidé que
comme pour les garçons a pris mon
certificat d'études primaires auprès de
la seule l'école communale du village
je devais poursuivre sa scolarité il
fallait donc quitter la maison pour
aller en ville ma belle-mère bien sûr si
elle te poser
je vais échapper et pour elle c'est
qu'encore des dépenses tout à fait
inutile mais mon père a cogné mans il
n'a pas cédé
je suis donc allé en ville au bout de
quelques années c'est à l'école la ville
que j'ai pu obtenir mon brevet
élémentaire
j'ai poursuivi ensuite allé au lycée
juliette dodu qui était le seul lycée de
jeunes filles de la rhino à cette époque
là mais mon père à la fin de la guerre
dans les années qui fait la guerre avec
de très très mauvaise affaire et il
avait du mal à remonter la pente
je crois comme un bleu vert il était
aussi pour quelque chose
je voyais bien que c'était difficile
pour lui de faire face aux frais de
scolarité aux frais de pension
régulièrement et je commençais à panique
je voulais surtout pas à retourner dans
mon village pour être à nouveau le
souffre douleur des mains de ma belle
mère même si j'étais encore très jeune
malgré une civilité paralysante qui me
m'empêcher vraiment de m'épanouir
j'ai cherché du travail et j'ai trouvé
très vite j'ai trouvé très bien le
travail dans une banque d'abord et puis
j'ai passé des examens des concours et
j'ai été recruté
plus tard dans une administration
l'administration des eaux et ferait
aujourd'hui s'appelle le l'office
intenable et forêts entre temps j'avais
rencontré celui qui allait devenir mon
mari
le no renault c'est le diminutif de
renault nous nous sommes mariés en 1953
nous avons eu deux enfants un garçon et
une fille ensuite nous avons eu cinq
petits enfants et aujourd'hui j'ai même
un arrière petit fils de 4 ans il faut
mon bonheur ce sont mes amours c'est le
centre de magie
lorsque j'ai commencé à travailler les
femmes étaient consignées dans les
postes de secrétaire ou les pauses 200
artistes
les hommes se sait les hommes qui
occupaient les postes des décisions les
postes de responsabilité je trouvais ça
tellement injuste
malgré le handicap de ma timidité je le
suis dit n'y a pas de raison que je leur
prouve que la compétence n'est pas du
domaine uniquement vasculaires j'ai
quand tu avais forme et je me suis
inscrite aux cours du soir l'université
lorsque je suis entré j'ai oublié de
dire quand je suis rentré ou aux accords
et j'étais donc recruté comme agent de
bureau c'est à dire au poste le plus bas
de la fonction publique et avec ses
différents ces termes je suis passé en
quelques années donc de ce poste d'agent
bureau un poste de cadre supérieur
auprès de la direction
je poussais j'étais une bosseuse j'étais
apprécié de la direction et j'espère que
j'ai réussi ma famille et je pense que
ma carrière j'ai réussi j'en suis très
fier dans un milieu d'hommes il n'y
avait dans al
quand je travaillais quand j'ai commencé
à aux eaux et forêts et il n'y avait que
deux secrétaires femmes toutes les
autres personnes étaient des hommes
c'est une administration on avait
pratiquement que des hommes et donc dans
un milieu masculin
j'ai montré j'ai démontré que j'avais
trouvé ma place et que je me faisais
respecter mes jeux ce problème de de
discrimination sexiste ce problème entre
les femmes et les hommes c'est quelque
chose qui peut qui me dérange énormément
et je que je voulais ajouter mon grain
de sel
mais je me suis dit peut-être de la
politique avec de la politique mais je
me suis rendu compte à ce moment-là que
la politique était aussi le domaine
réservé aux hommes donc je crois que ce
serait pas allée très loin et donc j'ai
choisi un domaine qui correspondait
beaucoup plus à mon tempérament quelque
chose que j'avais gta dépendant j'avais
les mains libres où je pouvais être plus
utile en tout cas être plus efficace le
domaine associatif
j'ai commencé à créer en 1986 une
première association qui s'appelait la
fare l'association par l'actuelle mairie
nous n'avions pas d'argent mais nous
avions réussi à nous faire entendre les
avons même une odeur doublement je
dirais nous avons rencontré des
personnes vraiment très très importante
par exemple michel debré que j'ai
rencontrés lors de manifestations que
nous avons fait également mais la dette
chirac était la fin des foyers ministre
et qui était venu à la réunion pour
inaugurer des floralies et qui qui nous
avait reçu en privé à la préfecture à la
suite d'un courrier que je verrai quand
j'y pense aujourd'hui je me dis aux
innocents les mains pleines pendant
cette expérience associative et aux six
pay ans de vie je me suis rendu compte
que c'est une égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes étaient du cercle à un
système social dirigé par des hommes
mais aussi par aussi une éducation
familiale qui faisait la part belle aux
garçons quand un gars sont arrivés de
ressorts iv c'était un don du ciel
dans ma famille je l'avais perdu 106 a
finalement mon père je crois qu'il était
assez moderne par rapport un rapport à
ça et je crois que c'est un peu grâce
aussi à lui que je me suis lancé corps
et l'âme dans cette lutte pour l'égalité
des chances de mes concitoyennes giran
j'ai créé l'amafar en 1992 je suis resté
13 ans à
anna mal à faire je suis resté dix ans
je suis resté 13 ans à ma femme et j'ai
quitté lama faire en 2007 que mon mari
avait des problèmes de santé moi même je
n'étais plus très jeune et je souhaitais
je souhaitais grande ma retraite qui
n'en a pas été une puisque j'ai très
vite à nouveau créé notre association le
cevif depuis peu le temps à rester une
année de plus sur les épaules
ce qui amène le compteur à 86 g 86
printemps et c'est peut-être aussi l'âge
de la sagesse
un auteur connu a dit que les trappes
déjà sagesse était de ne pas écouter le
mal avait pas voir le mal est de ne pas
dire du mal
j'ai un bris qui j'ai essayé d'appliquer
est ce qu'il disait et j'ai ajouté un
quatrième je ne veux pas faire de mal
aux autres
je pense que dans notre monde
aujourd'hui l'autre monde qui est
difficile
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est important
pour chaque embauche un col de nous d'y
apporter notre petite pierre faut
construire seconde beaucoup plus humain
beaucoup plus juste beaucoup plus
épanouissant pour notre société ce monde
d'aujourd'hui et amendes qui est dur
c'est au nom de ces pas ce monde que
nous voulons pour nos enfants
je me devrai aussi vous dire que
d'entretenir leurs prestations
l'apparence le cache souvent l'essentiel
il est important aujourd'hui d'aller
vraiment voir les gens pour voir chaque
être humain pour moi il a au fond de lui
peut-être tryphon de l'huile et là une
humanité que nous avons à découvrir
je pense qu'aujourd'hui notre rôle c'est
aussi d'avoir d'avoir ce regard qui peut
sauver quelqu'un d'avoir d'étendre la
mer
pour lou reed est quelqu'un qui a des
soucis pour pour qu'elle puisse en
sortir
je pense qu'aujourd'hui notre rôle c'est
vraiment ça aujourd'hui notre rôle c'est
de répondre de l'amour c'est ce qui
manque le plus à notre société
aujourd'hui cet amour qui est absolument
important pour qu'on puisse continuer à
vivre normalement et en tout cas des
vals surprise épanouie on dit que
l'amour ça ne coûte rien et ça n'a pas
de prix
alors je crois que nous n'avons pas nous
en priver en privé les autres faire du
bien aux jambes
ça nous fait et bien rendre heureux les
gens nous vend également heureux alors
je pense que nous devrions nous en
priver ça pourrait être une belle règles
de vie rendre les gens heureux
ça nous rend heureux vous savez moi j'ai
juste
aujourd'hui je suis en paix avec avec
mon passé j'ai pratiqué cet adage fait
la paix avec ton passé pour ne pas
ruiner temps présent est en aveux dire
donc c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
aujourd'hui être en paix avec moi même
essayé aussi de dispenser de la paix
autour de moi est de voir chez kibo
j'avais quelques fois on n'a pas le
temps porte pas le nez sur le but en
permanence comme c'était mon cas n'a pas
eu tant de bordes
les petites choses simples qui sont
tellement belles les fleurs monjardet le
boléro de ravel toutes ces choses toutes
ces petites btcc joie face à ces joueurs
simples que qu'on ne voit pas on apprend
tour de voir qu'ils pourtant l'ofii
tellement des biens
aujourd'hui alors pour terminer conclure
je voudrais vous dire accepter l'amour
que je vous offre
je vous le donne c'est vraiment de tout
mon coeur merci
[Applaudissements]